Shayne is probably a pretty good yeah
Marvel's daredevil stars tease the
Netflix shows insane second season
including the introduction of Punisher
played by Walking Dead alum Jon Bernthal
his character means a lot to a lot of
people and it means a lot to me it's an
unbelievable honor to get to be a part
of telling the story and I look at it as
a responsibility in the Marvel Universe
these superheroes appear across projects
but has daredevil Charlie Cox been
offered a role in the next Avengers film
infinity war I don't know if you like
teen want that oh yeah I mean can you
imagine that me so it would be the
coolest thing ever but no I've got that
I have no idea what that with that whole
how those you know Marvel TV and mobile
shoots you have achieved if very
different things you know even if the
character was to appear in in that film
that doesn't necessarily mean that I
would appear in the film I will pick a
fight with the guy and always yeah it
looks now a Twitter feud but um yeah
that would be a dream but it's not
something that has been